everyone out there welcome welcome in to
another edition of Market takes I'm your
host Dion rabone reporter at the Wall
Street Journal as you see we are swagged
up today we had a bunch of surprises
exciting stuff uh in store for you today
but we are talking about the third
quarter U.S GDP report gross domestic
product what the U.S made what it lost
what it earned and for those of you who
are you know excited about economic
growth you got reason to be excited
today after two straight quarters of
negative GDP growth we are back on the
positive side and back on the positive
side in a solid way we're going to get
into all that we're going to talk about
a lot of things within this report we're
going to talk about the headline numbers
of course we're going to look at the
markets talk about the market reaction
from that stocks bonds Commodities
currencies crypto we're going to do all
of that we're going to talk about how
this GDP report compared with the
expectations that we had coming in as
well as how it fits with other data
we've seen from the third quarter what
that can tell us about maybe the fourth
quarter the year so far all that good
stuff we're also going to talk about
what this means for the market as well
as for the economy because as we know
those two things have not been you know
on the level with one another uh in the
recent past few years and of course
we're going to talk about what to watch
for next that's going to be big and
we'll get into what you need to look for
now that we've gotten this report that
was highly anticipated and what goes
next
um before we jump into all that though
there's another big thing happening this
morning that's the European Central Bank
just announced they're raising rates by
75 basis points or 0.75 percentage Point
as we say here at the journal for some
reason uh so that's another thing that
you've got to watch out for this was
largely in line with expectations but
ECB president Christine Lagarde is
speaking right now so that's going to
have some effect on other markets
particular the value of the US dollars
so keep that in mind we're talking
through what's going on in markets today
because the ECB is catching up they're
they're at least raising rates right now
their rate is one and a half percent
compared to the FED at 3.25 and feds
expected to get to four percent next
week again just something to keep in
mind as we look out at the markets and
the overall you got to look at
everything right the big picture so
let's jump into this GDP report because
that's why you're all here we're talking
about that and what's going on US GDP in
the third quarter Rose by 2.6 and I want
to just bring up a chart that's right we
got charts ladies and gentlemen uh to
show you and just illustrate a few
things going back 10 years as you see
this chart on your screen
um you can see GDP has been you know
pretty small we've been inching up a
little bit if you take out those big
swings in 2020 right we all remember q1
Q2 Q3 of 2020 that's the pandemic
lockdowns and then the big get back from
that but then the last two quarters
before this quarter you saw are negative
but they're small negatives remember
aside from that 2020 period we hadn't
seen a negative quarter of growth since
2014. so those two negative back to back
cores of GDP growth were really
worrisome for a lot of people and now
you see that pickup there at the end on
the right side so just wanted to show
you that to illustrate where we've been
and where we are and just why we are
where we are now and why this report was
so important look the big thing from the
report I want to read you a little bit
from the report uh what it said was the
increase in Real GDP reflected increases
in exports consumer spending
non-residential fixed investment federal
government spending State local
government spending uh there were
decreases in fixed investment private
inventory but there was a subtraction
from Imports meaning we increased
exports decreased Imports that's a good
thing for GDP uh the big picture what
all that stuff means is just about
everything increase you saw a pretty
solid number if we'd gotten this number
back in 2019 or or 2018 you know
pre-pandemic this would have been a
solid report report and something she
could hang your hat on and feel pretty
good about where the economy was headed
but we are not in 2018 or 2019 right now
we're in an environment where the
Federal Reserve is trying to slow down
growth is trying to really rein in the
economy and and kind of Choke off some
of that growth so that inflation can
come back down and that really is a is
priority number one for the market
because how goes the FED is how goes the
market and we've seen that recently
there's been some expectations for the
FED to kind of chill out a little bit
we're going to talk about how this
report is going to factor into what we
expect to hear from them next week at
their November meeting as well as what
we can expect to hear in December uh at
that meeting so economic growth in the
health of the economy looking solid from
this report after those two negative
reports that we saw in the first and
second quarter this report suggests
things are getting better uh the
recession debate you know if we had had
a third quarter of negative growth which
it looked like we might as recently as
September uh that would have been a real
bad thing in terms of why we are going
into a recession if we're not already in
a recession if we have not already had a
recession that's for the National Bureau
of economic research to decide I don't
get a say but we did have those two
quarters of negative economic growth now
we have rebounded very clearly from that
up 2.6 percent uh that's quarterly GDP
up 2.6 after those two negative quarters
so for the market this the FED is going
to be diving into this very closely and
I'm going to talk to you about what the
FED will be looking for as it reads
through it and dives into this report uh
just a little bit later also notable
that core pce inflation came in as
expected 4.5 percent so not jumping off
the charts not an upside surprise as we
have seen from the recent pce and CPI
inflation reports that's definitely a
good thing for the market and something
that folks out there investors Traders
can take a little bit of solace in in
terms of when they look out at the
market and what's going on
as we look out at the stock market right
now and at the overall market Dow Jones
Industrial Average is booming up 1.3
percent the S P 500 up about half a
percent uh the NASDAQ up just a little
bit 0.06
uh the stock market really not where the
want where the big action is except for
that Dow print keep an eye on that we
had those big negative numbers from
Microsoft Facebook a couple others
yesterday on the tech side so the NASDAQ
really being dragged down by some
individual stories but if you look out
at the Dow boom up 1.3 percent today uh
when we look at it bonds that's where I
think the really interesting story is
you've got a big dive in yields at the
longer end of the curve and really
across the board with uh the bond market
you see that right around that eight
o'clock 8 30 of time excuse me right
around the 8 30 time when we got the
release of the GDP data you're just
seeing a big turn down in bond prices
bond prices have been coming down for a
while as expectations for the FED not to
raise their rates up to five six seven
percent you know a lot of folks were
worried about buying bonds because
they're saying we don't know when the
fed's gonna stop we don't know how much
hiking they're going to do this report
seems to have put a little bit of
confidence back in the bond market as we
see folks going out buying those bonds
bond yields go down as prices rise so
we're seeing a lot of buying uh in the
price change you're seeing at the
10-year actually a 23 basis points today
on the price side that's a big move for
the 10-year
um and also you know with the other big
Market that folks have been talking
about and maybe not talking about enough
as far as I'm concerned is the dollar
you're seeing the Euro down point seven
five percent against the dollar uh the
wsga dollar Index only up 0.34 but the
US dollar Index up 0.63 US dollar Index
a lot more a lot more motivated and
moved by the price change in the Euro uh
right now folks really not liking what
they're hearing from ECB president
Christine Lagarde in terms of uh Euro
Bulls they're selling the Euro the Euro
down about 0.75 versus the dollar but
most other currencies kind of holding
firms so you're seeing the dollar only
about point three percent uh so as we
sort of step back right from the market
reaction because this this report it
moved things but it wasn't a huge was
kind of like the market saying okay
because what the market was really
worried about was this report was going
to be too hot that the number was going
to come in and GDP was going to be too
strong that we were going to have
something three or three and a half
percent that also showed that inflation
was still picking up that folks are
still spending money what we're seeing
is what the FED is doing with trying to
kind of Choke off some of that economic
growth looks to have been working in the
third quarter which means the FED can
kind of relax a little bit they don't
maybe need to do quite as much this year
and then going into 2023 and that was
what investors were really worried
about so up above expectations 2.6
versus 2.0 percent which is what we had
on factset uh some other folks were
saying 2.4 depending on which Economist
you talk to that number can move but 2.6
beating expectations
um and as like I said as recently as
September 27th there were expectations
for GDP to only be 0.3 then we saw some
numbers
um on let's see what was it here gross
private domestic investment that was
huge as well as the pce that inflation
report that we saw in late September
that pushed us up to about 2.3 and we've
really the expectations went up from
there and today we got 2.6 percent uh
checking out some of the details within
the report because those matter the GDP
deflator now if you're not an economic
nerd you probably don't follow that
super closely uh that was way down to
4.1 percent now that's huge because it
was at nine percent in the second
quarter uh that basically GDP deflator
is a measure of inflation and the higher
that number is the more inflation is
contributing to GDP so in the second
quarter you had a negative print
negative point six percent GDP growth in
the second quarter but you had nine
percent on the GDP deflator this month
we've got 2.6 percent positive growth
and only 4.1 percent on the GDP deflator
that that's big in terms of saying
inflation is starting to cool down and
the GDP deflator doesn't measure a
basket of goods it's just everything
that was produced in the economy what
were the prices how was it moving and
that's definitely a good sign so the FED
can take some Solace from that GDP price
deflator it's also considered more
comprehensive than the Consumer Price
Index so you know we we saw that report
from Nick Tim Rose my colleague here at
the Wall Street Journal saying the FED
is is looking to raise 75 basis points
in November but then slow its role in
December and that there are some folks
worried about what's going to come next
year this really backs the case for the
FED to kind of slow its role and chill
out a little bit maybe not have to raise
rates quite so high not have to do quite
so much to choke off growth in the
economy
um look we've seen a continued slowdown
in jobs before the FED for whatever
reason is pointed to jobs growth even
though we have seen wages not growing as
fast as inflation we've seen a real
slowdown in wage growth even as overall
inflations continue to stay high but the
FED has pointed to that and we have seen
slowing job growth we have also seen
retail sales flattening out but not
going negative not turning into a
negative report so overall the economy
is looking like from this report that we
could see higher odds or higher
likelihood of that soft Landing that the
FED really wants to achieve where they
bring inflation down but they don't
choke off growth and don't send us into
a painful recession really what a lot of
economists are saying right now is that
it's not a matter of whether we'll have
a recession it's a matter of how bad or
how painful that recession will be well
from the looks of this Q3 report the
recession might not be that painful
things can continue moving as they
happen but again remember economic
policy and monetary policy in particular
works on a lacks when the Federal
Reserve raises interest rates as they've
been doing since March of this year
every single meeting
that works in a lag it doesn't hit the
economy right away so you could see the
impact from those rate hikes that
they've been doing all year and will
continue to do through December as
they've suggested uh start to hit the
economy in 2023 and we don't really know
what the impact is going to be uh the
big takeaway look this suggests the
market and the economy I'm sorry not the
market this suggests that the economy is
in pretty good shape and that inflation
did start to slow down that some of the
things the Federal Reserve wants to see
are happening within the economy that
GDP deflator is going to be big pce core
coming in on the nose at 4.5 that's good
there's really not a lot in this report
that you can look to it says okay the
FED needs to be more aggressive and
that's what the market and Wall Street
wants to see in terms of stocks getting
better look we have seen stock prices
really kind of pick up consistently
since October 12th and this really gives
Wall Street another reason to say hey
you know what maybe things aren't so bad
let's go out and buy stocks so what to
watch for in in the future after we've
gotten this report now we've kind of
settled in we've said okay GDP is
backward looking we know what happened
Q3 was probably you know maybe a small
win but a win for the Federal Reserve
what's next well the fed's going to talk
to us on November 2nd that's next
Wednesday be right here we'll be talking
through it on Market takes I'll be with
you hopefully you'll be with me we'll be
on YouTube talking through that meeting
talking about the report the uh you know
what we hear from fed share palette is
press conference all that and getting
into everything there as well as the
next report after that is going to be
the job support on Friday so you've got
the FED meeting and the jobs report next
week could be a very momentous week for
the market all eyes will be on fed share
Jerome Powell next week on Wednesday
November 2nd hopefully all eyes will be
here on Market takes from y'all I look
forward to seeing you then
uh and of course the other thing to look
out for before we get into next week
tomorrow the employment cost index is
out on Friday check that out make sure
you're watching that because the FED
pays a lot of attention to that they've
like I said they've pointed out the jobs
the increase in wages and jobs and said
that's the thing that we need to choke
off look out for that if you're watching
the market hey like I said our next live
stream here on Market takes is going to
be next Wednesday November 2nd or
Wednesday November 2nd talking about the
FED I hope you'll be there and you won't
be a
that's a square don't do it uh listen I
am Dion Robert Bowen for the Wall Street
Journal that's going to do us for here
for us on Market takes hope you'll be
with us next time